[Musique]
demain il y aura la projection de films
de frédérique bedos 2 le matin ce sera
10h30 canadienne un film qui rendra
hommage à jean vanier humaniste et
fondateur de l'association l'arche
bonjour bertrand figarol bonjour merci
de me recevoir
vous êtes un des membres du conseil
national de la fédération et responsable
de la région méditerranée et outre mer
de passage en martinique large qui
s'occupe des personnes en situation de
handicap intellectuel nous parlerons des
moyens déployés pour venir en aide à ces
personnes mais il faut quand même
rappeler ce matin nos auditeurs bertrand
figarol il est nécessaire de rappeler
l'histoire de jean vanier fils du
gouverneur général du canada en 64 1964
il rencontre deux personnes atteintes de
handicap mental
oui alors jean vanier est né avec une
petite cuillère en argent dans la bouche
pour ce qu'il est et fils du gouverneur
général
il a commencé par une carrière militaire
dans la marine britannique
et puis il a décidé d' ordre de
réorienter sa vie les progressivement la
réorienter vers les plus fragiles et en
64 effectivement il fait la connaissance
de deux personnes en situation de
handicap mental qui viennent l'aider à
retaper une grange dans un tout petit
village au nord de paris qui s'appelle
trosly-breuil et c'est comme ça que lui
qui était un intellectuel parce qu'il
avait fait une licence et un doctorat de
philosophie qu'il avait commencé il
avait accepté une chaire à toronto au
canada
ils découvrent des personnes qui
n'avaient que très peu de capacités
intellectuelles et les séduit par leurs
capacités relationnelles et c'est ainsi
que des larges qui accueille aujourd'hui
plus de 1200 personnes dans 33
communautés en france c'est ça alors on
à en avoir un petit peu augmenté les
chiffres
on est plutôt vers 1500 personnes
on et 154 communautés dans le monde et
ici sur l'arc antillais
il ya deux communautés en haïti est une
communauté à saint domingue
oui et puis en martinique il ya cette
association l'association larbi et du
coeur qui relaie ce message de l'art
chez nous oui alors l'association locale
avait du coeur a été fondé il ya cinq
ans c'est une magnifique réalisation
avec des gens de toutes provenances très
dynamique j'accompagne plusieurs projets
et je dois dire que celui ci est
particulièrement dynamique
alors le handicap mental bertrand fille
carole comment le définir exactement si
je prenais une image lorsque une fleur
une rose mettons comment sa croissance
elle peut aller jusqu à s'épanouir
totalement
et puis après suivant les chocs de la
nature la génétique elle ce vrai un peu
ça c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
handicap psychique si quelqu'un qui a
des capacités intellectuelles développer
mais qui sont vrillé et le handicap
mental c'est la personne qui reste en
boutons la fleur reste en boutons ses
capacités se sont pas totalement
développées elle a une certaine
compréhension des choses mais pas total
par contre elle est très douée dans
beaucoup de domaines et surtout dans le
domaine relationnel
c'est quelque chose de difficile à
détecter c'est quelque chose qu'on
détecte délai dès les premiers temps de
la vie mais très progressivement les
parents constatent que l'évolution de
leur petit bébé est plus lente
on a parlé longtemps de retard
intellectuel ou maintenant au canada ont
dit des personnes avec difficulté
d'apprentissage franco-canadien faut le
préciser ça donc cette difficulté
d'apprentissage fait que
les enfants dans leur fratrie par
exemple après moins vite que les autres
et ils sont un peu décalé par rapport
aux autres et ça inquiète beaucoup les
parents alors est-ce que l'autisme par
exemple peut être considérée comme un
handicap mental
alors la réponse est complexe à la
question simple c'est à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de formes d'autisme tout un
spectre et d'ailleurs on parle du
spectre des troubles autistiques
chez certaines personnes autistes ils
ont au contraire une capacités
intellectuelles supérieures à la moyenne
dans certains domaines en particulier
tout ce qui est comptabilité et
comptabilité visuel d'ailleurs dans le
film rain man dustin hoffman
on voit la personne capable de compter
le nombre d'allumettes tomber par terre
c'est une image pour le film assez
holyrood mais ça se sait si c'est la
réalité il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
ont cette forme d'autisme qu'on appelle
notice asperger qui ont des capacités
extraordinaires sur le pont du comptage
al'inverse il ya aussi des personnes qui
ont des troubles du spectre autistique
qui sont aussi avec un handicap mental à
dire qu elles l ont beaucoup difficultés
d'apprentissage donc beaucoup de choses
dépendent aussi de la manière dont elles
peuvent être accompagnés prise en charge
et si je l'accident par exemple de la
route et que ben écoutez je ne dispose
plus de toutes mes facultés
est ce qu'on peut considérer que je suis
handicapé mental alors les trop la prise
en charge des ja oui oui c'est vrai que
les troubles cd du qui sont ce qu'ils
sont liés au handicap qui sont ceux du
pardon qui sont liées à l'accident qui
sont souvent des traumatismes
alors autrefois on disait autrement mais
maintenant on dit des traumatismes
cérébraux médullaire donc provoque des
difficultés de compréhension des
difficultés d'apprentissage qui sont
proches du handicap
souvent il ya aussi les troubles
associés des troubles de la locomotion
des troubles d'un handicap physique
quelle est la réalité de la prise en
charge du handicap mental dans ce pays
qu'elle représente la france la france
ces bruits pas trop de mal par rapport à
beaucoup de pays du monde où la prise en
charge du handicap intervient bien après
toutes sortes d'autres préoccupations au
népal par exemple moi je vais souvent en
inde mais au népal le premier ministre
avait dit que le handicap était un luxe
pour les pays occidentaux mais c'est
vrai que la france a depuis longtemps
découvert comment on pouvait faire la
différence entre les personnes qui
avaient des difficiles des difficultés
d'apprentissage et puis des personnes
qui étaient handicapés psychiques
autrefois ils étaient tous mélangés dans
les hôpitaux psychiatriques et beaucoup
de l'association de parents sont créés
la plus célèbre c'est l'unapei qui à son
antenne ici en martinique l'adapei et
qui ont énormément fait pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
mental
alors il m'envoie une mois pour une
meilleure prise en charge sont des
moyens financiers une volonté politique
ou bien tout simplement avec une
conscientisation de la part de nos élus
pour savoir avec ces personnes existent
des leçons combien on pourrait dire
qu'il manque tout ça actuellement on
peut dire qu'en martinique si on se
réfère aux chiffres de la mph la maison
martiniquaise du handicap il ya
vingt-cinq mille personnes qui sont
concernées
si on se réfère aux chiffres de l'insee
il ya presque 65000 personnes qui
seraient concernées
ton parti nick chamie oui oui donc il y
a une obligation de prise en charge ces
personnes de la gloire de nos élus oui
c'est à dire effectivement les
collectivités ont le devoir de prendre
en charge de s'intéresser à ces
personnes qui sont plus fragiles et qui
ont une grosse difficulté d'insertion
dans la
la vie sociale néanmoins quand on dit
devoirs etc
il y a le problème des moyens et s'ils
n'ont pas être facile pour les familles
actuellement c'est vraiment que c'est un
souci et surtout en martinique parce que
la martinique
à la différence de beaucoup de régions
de france en particulier la région
parisienne qui est très très bien
fournie a très très peu d'établissements
a proposé aux personnes qui ne peuvent
pas travailler et elle a aussi un gros
déficit en l'hébergement donc là il ya
du rattrapage
je travaille dans la région de marseille
on est dans la même situation marseille
a un gros déficit et ils ont décidé de
mettre en oeuvre un plan avec des
créations de place donc ce qu'on espère
c'est qu'en martinique les choses vont
suivre aussi
néanmoins les moyens étant beaucoup plus
difficile à obtenir aujourd'hui forme de
générosité qui s'est développée alors il
ya une forme de générosité sur laquelle
on peut compter
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des associations
comme le carb et du coeur qui regroupe
des gens et qu'ils peuvent récolter des
dons mais il ya aussi le fait qu'on
cherche de nouvelles formes d'accueil en
structure en hébergement qu'ils ne
soient plus des établissements
médico-sociaux qui avait le mérite
d'offrir des solutions à un grand nombre
mais qui se sont avérées au fil du temps
assez coûteuse et aujourd'hui on parle
plus d'habitat inclusif puisque ça
répond à une double demande à la fois la
demande des personnes en situation de
handicap elle-même qui veulent être plus
insérés dans la société qui veulent
avoir leur studio plus d'autonomie être
dans les coeurs des villes et aussi aux
demandes des pouvoirs publics des
collectivités qui ont moins de moyens
vous dites qu'il faut briser les peurs
qui sont liées à cette situation de
handicap mental c'est le regard de la
population des autres qui feront gens
qu'il faut changer les louis-le
c'est-à-dire que les personnes avec un
handicap souvent souffrent du regard des
autres je me rappelle très bien avoir
été en suisse avec des personnes en
situation de handicap et tout d'un coup
il y en a un qui s'échappe du groupe
et qui me dit il me regarde voilà
et en fait c'est vrai c'était le regard
des gens des passants il avait une
démarche un peu et brieuc zh qui faisait
que il s'était senti vraiment agressé il
ya ça certainement mais la plupart du
temps on peut dire que les gens sont
bienveillants les gens sont accueillants
et ils ont de la compassion pour les
parents qui vivent avec des si des
personnes en situation de handicap
merci bertrand figaro la vérité avec non
appel que vous êtes membre de la
fédération de large et que demain ce
sera à 10h30 la projection du film jean
vanier le sacrement de la tendresse jean
vanier le créateur de large c'était en
1964 merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin dans son crédit bonne journée
merci de m'avoir invité